the greens will ensure everyone has a
secure affordable place to live how
would that be brought about well a
couple of things that we would want to
focus on here in terms of council
housing we want to build 500,000 use
social rent homes that means council
well what we want to do is fund that
particularly from removing the tax
relief on mortgage interest for private
landlords we have a situation where
private landlords private landlords at
the moment you basically running away
with a situation of hugely rising rents
they're collecting large amounts of
Housing Benefit how much would that be
worth the mortgage relief for private
landlords well that's the whole cost of
five hundred thousand homes
let's start with that how much is that
going to be right well that's got a
total cost that we will be spilt out in
our manifesto so you don't know so we
don't know how much those homes are
gonna cost but you do it with a weight
it's going to be funded is mortgage
relief from private handles how much is
that worth what we're looking at in
terms of the figures here what we need
to do is actually we're looking at the
total spin of 2.7 billion 500,000 homes
2.7 what are they made of plywood
basically what we're talking about is
500,000 new homes and basically each 1
pound spent on this brings about two
pounds forty number what is the total
cost of 500,000 homes it's a cost of
60,000 per home 60,000 people because
what we're talking about is the
opportunity for that I can't include the
land well what we're talking about is
what we want to see is the possibility
of homes being that's not much more than
a large conservatory 60,000 pounds so
where's the lab how are you going to pay
for the land right what we're looking at
doing is is is basically
right sorry yes I see as you can
probably hear I've got a a huge cold so
so what we need to do is basically
social rental homes right still don't
see how you're gonna get this some at
sixty you don't actually know how much
it's going to cost to you yet we have we
have a fully costed program which will
be releasing you'd be aware of what that
cost would be now right yes so what
we're talking about is six billion a
year so it's the current budget is 1.5
billion a year that will be attained by
taking mortgage relief from private
landlords that's six billion pounds and
we're also looking at investing yeah
well we've got the fully costed figures
here you said that on a couple of
occasions
how much does mortgage relief from
private animals bring in then basically
we're talking about an overall saving of
4.5 billion pounds we're looking at
housing benefit reforms and what we also
want to do is bring in caps on private
tenants yeah do you think you might have
perhaps agenda up on this a bit more
Natalie Bennett I think that we're
talking about a whole range ended up a
little bit much of it made into this a
perhaps a little more in hindsight what
we're talking about is a whole range of
issues this morning raining from the
economy from the NHS